partie pizza la résidence c'est une
bonne idée et c'est vraiment un parti
pris et c'est vraiment une bonne idée
mais effectivement on essaye de faire
les bonnes petites choses des bons
petits plats on essaye de vraiment de
faire plaisir aux voisins à la famille
aux amis
ça traduit vraiment l'ambiance et essai
du coup c'est chaleureux pour le coup ça
ça met du baume au coeur
[Musique]
toujours sur une sur des choses
classiques vraiment sur la même trame
les burgers les pizzas les bons petits
mails et les gratins les couscous les
et voilà tout ce qui est tous les petits
plats convivial et les plats du dimanche
on va dire c'est qu'on filme en plus la
chance de faire découvrir aussi ma
cuisine ma façon de travailler mes
méthodes de travail et et surtout aussi
pour faire faire profiter chacun au
voisin voilà comme comme j'ai dis
surtout sur un esprit de convivialité et
voilà même si le confinement c'est
facile on s'ennuie pas du coup ne
s'ennuie pas on arrive à passer le temps
en cuisinant j'ai vraiment la chose
avant de faire quelque chose que j'aime
donc c'est vraiment c'est vraiment un
plaisir
effectivement c'est plus qu'une passion